both things have to keep their nerve and
cook the dish of their lives
hi guys let's call chef min al cow she
last course keep it going yes okay end
on a high yes from their small deli
attached to the restaurant in Bradford
for shard serve a huge range of
deliciously sweet Indian desserts which
calcium are now are attempting to
modernize for their final dish they hope
will win them this competition we making
homemade Indian sweet this sweets is a
delicate same time is a rich also Gordon
will definitely like it he liked my food
so I'm sure he liked this one also all
three of their traditional Indian
desserts use a combination of ghee flour
and sugar either refined white or the
Indian favorite jaggery an unrefined
sugar that is extremely sweet but
extremely popular in Indian desserts
sesame seeds and they are gonna get
together very well
one is rolled with sesame seeds another
is flattened spiced with cardamom then
finished with pistachios and almonds and
the third and final sweets is a simple
blend of sesame seeds and jaggery that
is cut into squares and the finished
dish will be washed down with sweetened
ginger tea in India people how they
think that the half meals have water
boiling out put some ginger and sugar
and keep boiling until it's really good
taste
I think Prasad have been clever to
create a simple dish that is easy to
plate and requires very little cooking
during service
it's a nice way of finishing a classic
main course what I like about it is
quite modern and they've sort of taking
a leaf out of kazimierz book there but
well they're doing that with Italian
food I can do that with vegetarian
Indian food clever they look fantastic
but before I make my own mind up I want
to see what my experts and diners think
of these modernized Indian sweets I was
quite excited why they make them look
almost like sort of little miniature
petit fours
yeah very very pretty but they were just
i'm awfully sweet sometimes you get
sugar rush this kind of gave me a sugar
bash on the head yeah just too much very
different but then they're quite
traditional within themselves so I
thought that was a nice mixture of old
and new and trying to mixed up a bit I
like the one at the end which was the
slightly hard one to me mainly because
it was less sweet you know it had a
great structure to it you know had a
lovely - a buttery nutty flavor to it I
don't think they'll ever get away from
those over sweetness star but I have to
applaud them for their modernization of
a dessert all right yeah I think I did a
great thing today actually flavors on
this one only remind me everyone in the
restaurant is very spicy very very
fragrant but I actually bit into them
there was one sesame loved to which
people that was really nice I really
like that I don't like ginger tea at all
but I like that ginger tea wasn't to
gingery by my master days